derniers préparatifs avant le décollage
des gestes répétés mille fois pendant
l'entraînement mais pour ces militaires
canadiens cette fois c'est bien réel
avec leur hélicoptère ils sont déployés
dans le ciel de l'est du mali dans le
cadre de la minus marque
la mission de stabilisation de l'onu une
opération qui marque le grand retour des
casques bleus canadiens
la première mission militaire canadienne
d'envergure sous pavillon de l'onu
depuis la bosnie c'est quelque chose
d'historique un peu pour nous
je pense que c'est naturellement
canadien peut aider des personnes
d'aider notre idée des revenus de d'être
de service des soldats de l'onu on est
très fiers de la mission ici
[Musique]
minus ma c'est plus de 12 mille soldats
de cinquante sept nationalités
différentes
en comparaison la contribution
canadienne de 250 hommes et femmes peut
paraître modeste mais elle constitue
pourtant un élément essentiel
les canadiens sont venus avec ses
hélicoptères de transport et de combat
un outil précieux car le mali est vaste
très vaste désertique et sans
infrastructures
ces hélicoptères chinook de nouvelle
génération ont donc immédiatement été
mise à profit pour envoyer de
l'équipement sauter offrir aussi un
transport rapide et sûr pour des soldats
déployés dans des zones isolées comme
ces militaires allemands qui reviennent
d'une mission de deux jours le long du
fleuve niger
mais la mission première des canadiens
est d'offrir un service d'évacuation
aéro médicale pour tous les soldats de
l'onu ici et ce militaire allemand
ramener d'urgence à gao a été parmi les
premiers à en bénéficier
une mission très exigeante car les
équipages doivent rester disponibles 24
heures sur 24
prêts à décoller en moins de 30 minutes
vétéran de l'afghanistan le major
dominic simard qui pilotait déjà des
hélicoptères chinook
mais la mission malienne lui tient
particulièrement à coeur
notre mission principale est 6e au mali
c'est aller chercher des personnes sont
blessées tant qu'on va voler les équipes
médicales répète en permanence histoire
d'être prêt à toute éventualité d
entraînement qui permettent aussi
d'affiner les procédures car ces soldats
sont des pionniers
c'est la première fois que le canada
envoie des médecins des spécialistes en
première ligne en zone hostile à bord
des hélicoptères de sauvetage
la première fois qu'ils ont d'abord à
leur disposition des produits sanguins
prête à transfuser le chinois médicalisé
n'est pas seulement une ambulance
c'est un hôpital volant
mais cet hôpital volant est aussi
équipés de mitrailleuses lourdes
escortés est protégé en permanence par
des hélicoptères de combat car le mali
d'aujourd'hui est aussi très dangereuse
théâtre depuis 2013 d'insurrection et de
nombreuses attaques terroristes
alors c'est un environnement
incroyablement complexe beaucoup de
factions armées ils sont à aligner des
fois une un groupe ethnique des fois une
à une groupe terroriste avec déjà plus
de 170 morts la minustah est de loin la
mission de l'onu la plus dangereuse
actuellement car les groupes armés vise
directement les casques bleus et ceux
qui courent le plus de risques sont bien
évidemment les troupes au sol
alors les soldats et les policiers de
l'onu sur le terrain se déplacent
rarement son blindé sans escorte
lourdement armés si leur mission est de
ramener la sécurité au mali de rassurer
la population
les casques bleus sont aussi une cible
et plus ils sont déployés loin de leurs
bases
plus ils se sentent vulnérables face aux
risques d'embuscades et à la menace
d'engins explosifs improvisés eei à des
zones particulièrement difficile parfois
été très dangereux mais hot spot la
confiance de nos hommes réside dans le
fait qu'ils soient sûrs qu'à tout moment
s'il arrive quelque chose il faut
bénéficier d'une évacuation sanitaire
touchant aux déserts des canadiens
courent beaucoup moins de risques mais
le mali reste une zone hostile
le défi majeur c'est l'environnement
c'est la poussière et la chaleur une
chaleur qui dépassent souvent les 40
degrés des tempêtes de sable qui souffle
sans s'annoncer des conditions
extrêmement difficiles pour les hommes
et pour les machines un environnement
abrasif une mission que le canada a
promis elle aussi s'assurer au moins
jusqu'à l'été prochain
[Musique]
il